un brote de omicron en una fiesta de
navidad en noruega casos de propagación
comunitaria en islandia india y el reino
unido- la nueva variante se propaga por
el mundo los científicos dicen que no
pasará mucho tiempo antes de que un
micro supere a delta ymbro américas
pasará algún tiempo antes de que omicron
se establezca en francia y en europa en
general en el consejo científico
estimamos que será dominante más o menos
a principios de 2022 los datos concretos
sobre omicron son todavía escasos pero
la agencia sanitaria de la unión europea
dice que se cree que es más contagiosa
que las anteriores
también se cree que la variante de
responsable del reciente aumento de
casos en sudáfrica
la infección previa solía proteger
contra delta y ahora económico no parece
ser el caso sin embargo creemos que las
vacunas seguirán protegiendo contra la
enfermedad grave
ahora la atención se centra en la
preparación para la batalla y en
aumentar los esfuerzos para limitar el
impacto de omikron eeuu está lanzando
una campaña urgente de pruebas y
refuerzos corea del sur ha vuelto a
imponer 40 en las obligatorias a todos
los viajeros al extranjero alemania está
imponiendo fuertes restricciones a los
no vacunados y está considerando la
posibilidad de imponer la vacunación en
todo el país y la oms está financiando
un esfuerzo reforzado en el sur de
áfrica
como la organización también está
movilizando 12 millones de dólares para
apoyar las actividades de respuesta
crítica en los países de la región
durante los próximos tres meses las
autoridades sanitarias dicen que no hay
motivos para el pánico y que la mejor
defensa contra omicron sigue siendo la
vacunación el distanciamiento social y
las pruebas frecuentes